you know life is neither the ink nor the
water nor the mix it's the swirls humans
life is the swirls that happen in the
ink and life is a specifically kind of
swirl which looks for more ink and more
water to create more swirls so the idea
that a life resists entropy is not
exactly correct it's more like we ride
entropy it's more we're more like fire
than we are like you know ink we're not
a passive process we're a process that
releases energy and lives on the
gradient
between two energy sources you know
between a hot bath and a cold bath this
is where we live we live in between we
can neither exist in the cold nor in the
warm we can only exist on the Twilight
this is what life is you know life is
neither the ink nor the water nor the
mix it's the swirls humans life is the
swirls that happen in the ink and life
is a specifically kind of swirl which
looks for more ink and more water to
create more swirls so the idea that a
life resist